Speaker 1: Let's go next to Andrew from Missouri.
Welcome, Andrew.
Speaker 5: Yes.
Hello.
Hi.
You know, hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 5: Excellent.
So I am actually from the Ozarks in southwest
Missouri.
And I have seen a is alarming to me in the
last year and two years, really how many younger
people have kind of bought into the Trumpist
talking points and just Trumpism in general
anti Biden to the point that it it's one of
those things where I worry that we're not
going to see this pass as the older generation
passes that would that we're going to have
to deal with this for even longer.
And I'm just wondering, there's a couple of
points to this.
How do we combat this brainwashing of the
younger generations?
And like do these do these hearings help with
that?
Or they get a really or are you just going
to be ignored by people who are entrenched?
And then with that, do Democrats need to start
playing the unfortunately playing the political
theater game just to just to get their their
based riled up to combat Trumpism overall.
Speaker 1: So I don't think that young people
are necessarily watching the January 6th hearings
in any significantly large numbers.
So I wouldn't count on that.
And I actually have a different perspective,
which is although there are these young right
wing movements like Turning Point USA targeting
people on college campuses, I actually think
that the young folks are the ones that have
been least brainwashed and the ones that we're
sort of counting on.
So I don't see them as the biggest problem
to solve.
The, you know, the older Facebook conspiracy
folks seem like really the problem.
But of course, we want to make sure that we're
equipping young people with the tools so that
they never become indoctrinated in the first
place, including critical thinking skills,
media literacy, etc..
Speaker 5: Yeah.
Yeah.
And it's it's.
It's one of those.
Those things.
Where are we?
I don't know.
It feels like the right has such a stranglehold
on controlling the narrative.
Yep.
That that I don't know how we can combat that
effectively because they, they've been at
it for so long.
Speaker 1: I agree with you.
And I've talked about all of the things that
need to happen are the ones I already mentioned
here.
Also, the left needs to be as good and as
committed as the right to funding groups that
are working to grow the movement.
The right just throws money at it.
They don't care.
They won't stop.
And it's part of why they succeed.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Hey, real quick, Andrew, before
you go, can you name four countries that start
with the letter G out of curiosity?
Speaker 5: Four countries start the letter
G. Yeah, I got Georgia, Germany, Ghana and.
Let's get another one.
Oh, and that's on a stick.
Hmm.
Well, that's embarrassing.
Speaker 1: Well, I would have accepted Greece
or Guatemala.
Speaker 5: Greece?
Greece, I think.
Yeah.
There you go.
Speaker 1: All right, Andrew, thank you for
the call.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 5: Thank you very much.
Have a good one.
Speaker 1: All right.
You, too.
All right, guys.
Let's take a very quick break.
We're taking more calls, so don't hang up
if you're holding on.
We're going right back to the phones in a
moment